[Music]
today's question comes from chris in
tennessee with covet cases ramping up
again i'm wondering how to prepare in
case we have lockdowns again my
profession isn't one where i can work
from home what steps can i take now to
protect my family in case i'm not able
to work for several weeks
interesting
well uh i don't like people going into
paranoia about what could and what ifs
but several weeks sounds like something
that could be easily covered with an
emergency fund
where if you for some reason got laid
off
fired you'd be taken care of for three
to six months yeah but it sounds like
there's more behind this question than
just a financial question
yeah there's there he's afraid
um
and rightly so um because we've all had
our
uh world uh turned upside down and
shaking like a freaking snow globe
so um
you know we don't know what's gonna
happen next and it's not even the
disease you worry about all the time
it's whether the government loses its
mind or not
um and
well that's not even in question anymore
but the um
uh it's just a matter of from state to
state locality to locality how much crap
you're gonna get so he's in tennessee so
he's he's safer than most yeah he's
probably very safe in that regards um
huh
the thing about the stuff we teach
george
while we get criticized for it to be um
overly simplified or one-size-fits-all
or primitive or not for people with
money it's only for broke people or
whatever we get all these you know these
critics on this stuff and
um
the reason they're wrong
is not because
we're smarter or something like that the
things we teach are common sense
biblically based
financial principles
and the interesting thing about these
principles is they work during
times of crisis and they work during
times of prosperity
they're the only set of principles that
work during both times
and so if you're out of debt
principle number one
you have money in savings for an
emergency principle number two
you're living on a plan principle number
three
you are not self-centered so that you're
generous principle number four
uh you're surrounding yourself with
like-minded people principle number five
uh you're diversified
spread your portions to seven years to
eight for you do not know when disaster
may come upon the land
ecla ecclesiastes says in the bible
diversification is a biblical concept
it's also a financial concept
but you know
you know we're going to
live on less than we make we're not in
debt we're not co-signing debt
debt's off the table we're investing
wisely
uh what you are then is you have gone
the slower route and you have built the
brick house like the third pig
and so my answer to chris is be the
third pig
you remember the three little pigs right
the first two little pigs got their
house blown down by the big bad wolf
called pandemic and then he came over to
the other little pig who had a lot of
money in the bank and no debt and they
blew any huffing puff then he went to
somebody else's house
and um they said no bacon here buddy
and so uh you know that that's the story
we all remember it right
so be the third pig we're gonna need to
print up t-shirts be the third pig right
and so if you're the third pig
you are prospering during
wonderful times and you're prospering
during the pandemic
and
it has a tendency when you're not broke
to help you avoid paranoia
because this one sounds a little bit
paranoid yeah and
i think a lot of this is fear and we
dealt with this you know during the
pandemic we realized we were in a
position to go we need to help people
not just with money but with fear and
what was what was the antidote you found
to fear in the last 18 months we were
quoting dr john deloney the whole time
facts are your friends when you're in
the middle of a crisis
facts are your friends not feelings so
we need to go to reality here and so
you know the truth is chris if you're in
tennessee
if you get out of your house and walk
around
you're not going to see a society that
is shut down by covid
even though there was a slight spike in
cases which now are back down but um
you're not going to see
facts before your eyes that match your
words on this paper
the facts are your friends feelings are
not your friends and worry is a feeling
paranoia is a feeling
uh concern
over observable
craziness and stupidity
is a fact
and that's okay to be that i'm that
um i don't know what's gonna happen next
you know who knows what their people are
gonna do and i truly am more concerned
about an out of control government than
i am the disease
um both are scary uh
one of them though is not um
well anyway it's just yeah so you just
if you'll get out of your house and walk
around sir
and get out in the sunshine and exercise
you need some vitamin d
and um walk around see human beings
interacting that are not freaked out
they're not scared they're they're i
think you're going to have a different
conclusion
into your situation but
to answer your question about worrying
be the third pig
because these principles work in good
times and they work in bad times
george i remember
2008
when the
housing
bubble burst when the hedge funds had
securitized
subprime mortgages and stupidity had run
amok
and wall street brought the american
real estate market to its knees with it
the stock market stock market dropped in
half
bush is transitioning into obama
neither one of them could find their
butt with both hands at the time
and um it was a disaster
i mean it was scary
and i i remember distinctly i was on fox
news
i was in new york
and i finished cavuto's show kavuto and
i've been friends for years and cavuto
is very very smart
neil's a very bright man
we've known each other 20 years probably
and we're between breaks and
the octaves in his voice had changed he
was scared because we're watching that
red ticker tape go across the dadgum
thing you know six feet tall across the
side of the new york building and the
stock market's going down gold prices
are going up all these volatility signs
are not good
and he said you think we're gonna be
okay and i said i know we're gonna be
okay and i went and sat down there's a
steakhouse right across the street from
there and sharon and i left the fox
green room went across sat down and
ordered a steak and i'm looking at that
dad gum ticker tape and suddenly that
chill went down my spine
and i thought i wonder if we're gonna be
okay
and sharon and i were talking about it
that night at dinner and we said why are
we not scared
because everybody else at that point was
in freak out mode i mean we had
congressmen that were like crying on the
television because they couldn't get the
stimulus package passed you remember the
stimulus package you know that kind of
crap they were going crazy
and it was just like this panic
literally their voice octaves were
changing and i said why are we not
freaked out she said
it could be our faith and i said well
sometimes christians get afraid what's i
mean you're not christian i mean you
don't get afraid
and she said well could be we've got
several million dollars in the bank of
no debt oh well that could be that that
might have something to do with it
be the third pig chris
be the third pig